i
la presión diplomática española ha
frenado la crisis en ceuta marruecos ha
optado por controlar el flujo migratorio
para el gobierno español esta llegada de
8000 inmigrantes es la crisis
diplomática más grave desde que el
presidente del gobierno está en función
después del despliegue del ejército en
ceuta y la llamada a líderes europeos
pedro sánchez tiene una tarea pendiente
mejorar las relaciones con marruecos
tensas por el conflicto en el sáhara
occidental antigua colonia española pero
antes el gran problema es la atención a
menores los inmigrantes adultos están
siendo devueltos pero mil menores
habrían entrado en la ciudad autónoma el
ejecutivo intentar repartir los en las
comunidades autónomas pero varias
regiones gobernadas por la derecha se
muestran reticentes el partido de
extrema derecha box exige que nos acoja
a ningún menor
[Música]
50 muertos es el saldo del último
naufragio de migrantes que se ha
producido en las costas de túnez desde
allí intentan llegar a europa
principalmente a italia y españa- pero
son 633 los que han perdido la vida en
lo que va de año mientras 23 mil 500 han
logrado su objetivo de llegar a europa
según datos de naciones unidas para
evitar que lo hagan está hoy en túnez en
representante de la unión europea buscan
políticas en los países de origen de los
países de salida para evitar el tráfico
de seres humanos el control de fronteras
y también soluciones para devolver a
aquellos extranjeros que dicen no son
refugiados pero las organizaciones de
derechos humanos denuncian que estas
personas huyen de la guerra huyen de
regímenes que les suprime diré en el
primer y que lo que se intenta es
simplemente contener a seres humanos que
buscan una vida mejor
ah
se multiplican las llegadas de
emigrantes originarios del continente
africano a los puertos italianos en la
última semana más de dos mil migrantes
desembarcaron en la isla siciliana de
lampedusa y se teme que esto solo sea un
inicio ya que con la llegada del verano
las condiciones marítimas son favorables
para estas embarcaciones que transportan
cada año decenas de miles de migrantes
este jueves el ministro italiano del
interior hizo un llamado a la unión
europea para que se acepte el principio
de una distribución de estos migrantes
que pisan suelo italiano en los
diferentes estados miembros de la unión
el tema ha generado aquí en italia un
intenso debate político con matteo
salvini el líder de la ultraderecha
italiana quien reclama que se
desplieguen a las fuerzas armadas para
contener la llegada de estas personas en
los cinco primeros meses de este año más
de 13.000 inmigrantes han desembarcado
en los puertos italianos después de
haber atravesado el mar mediterráneo
[Música]